et carrelage et une petit truc un petit
truc pour toi j'aimerais que tu viennes
un petit peu faire de tpm paix avec nous
à la rentrée au moins une fois par
semaine car est ce que ça te dirait des
trains tp avec nous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est et restera miss ile de france
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis très heureux de voir si lui je
suis très heureux de rencontrer miss
france 2022 dernière elle est magnifique
et très vraiment j'avais voté pour vous
est ce que je suis de l'ile-de-france a
entendu alors vous êtes dans
l'immobilier tout à fait en promotion
promotion de c'est à dire c'est quoi
comme suit mobilières d'accord c'est
quand vous faites vous vendez des
apparts c'est un petit peu le stéphane
plaza mange
on boit beaucoup cité en ce moment non
mais c'est certain qu'on va se
rencontrer on pourra dire qu'on est
collègues megan je pense qu'il a envie
de rencontrer des vins locaux des
centres du peuple poursuit l'auteur de
rideaux raconte sur les disques olivier
bossé avant ou pas oui à fond quand on
fait des répétitions et ou alors vous
voulez à 100% et est bien sûr toujours
ici
le discours je l'échangé la veille ah
ouais ben alors qu'en fait c'est ce que
j'ai dans discours quand j'ai vu qu'ils
avaient il est vrai qu'à mettre ça dans
le jury je me suis dit j'ai pas faire de
blagues en fait ouais c'est absolument
impossible parce qu'elle voulait faire
des blagues au départ n'envoyez sait
tous pourquoi
joss dray mais je m'étais dit il faut
mettre un peu d'humour montrer sa
personnalité est rageant mais c'est en
fait si la blague et les ratés il ya
deux humoristes en face ses katas ses
katas way ne lui faut pas tenter la
blague et au final c'est ce qui a fait
rire les gens donc de dire ça et un
petit truc une petite polémique
mini-hand polémique a éclaté pendant
l'émission c'est en rapport avec les
cheveux de miss aquitaine selon les
internautes les coiffeurs ont massacré
sa chevelure un détail qui lui aurait
desservi je sais qu'il vous en faites
partie mais bon ça a été très déçu par
la coiffure de miss guyane je sais que
vous avez des plaintes
ah ah ah les bâtards j'aimais bien le
coin sur celle des matières non mais je
précise que moi j'étais avec elle engage
total a fait la coiffure c'est ce
qu'elle a demandé comme coiffure pascal
et à
droite pourquoi plus belles au naturel
comme ça moi je l'aimé alors si vous
regardez le mois en fait elles ont tout
plein de coiffure du temps qu'on leur
dise et que vous avez des coiffeurs des
matières qui sont là pour vous sublimer
d'accord vous ne quittez pas votre poste
de maquillage de coiffure sans que ça
vous plaise avions laissés libres de
leur image c'est important et est elle
vraiment libre
balle et ses réponses des annonces et en
massacrant capillaire je vous promets
que oui parce que on a pour le coup
sylvia raison tous les coiffeurs et
maquilleurs nous ont demandé si ça nous
plaisait ou non était libre de demander
le maquillage que l'on voulait mais la
coiffure que l'on vous d'accord mais ce
aquitaine c'était la deuxième fois qu'il
faisait cette coiffure pendant pendant
le genre général et elle l'adorait la
coiffure très monaco me sens faute
célibataire oui
j'ai senti un petit j'ai senti
attention
vous êtes célibataire oui peut-être sur
wii dont vous savez le droit de yom
nouvelle nation pourquoi pour la france
france est français tous les suspects et
les spectateurs qui vont être ravis j'ai
répondu très honnêtement cette question
c'est que je sais que normalement il ya
des miss qui veulent pas forcément
répondre moi je dis je suis célibataire
maintenant je ne suis pas un coeur à
prendre je vient d'accueillir beaucoup
de français dans mon coeur j'ai pas
forcément le temps pour quelqu'un s'est
passé au travail et déjà six corps
6 ch me ce qui vous plaît pas de
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la saison une a cartonné plus ça a été
un carton jaune à mi-saison une surman
canal un carton absolu donc qu'est ce
qui se passe quand c'est un carton
quelles raisons de taille canal jeudi à
on a trouvé la poule aux oeufs d'or
on veut une saison 2 ayant la même
saison 3
me sur noël et la saison 3 je crois que
c'est le mariage et ça c'est ça ce n'est
pas le dire à
tampa bay
alors donc la nouvelle saison sera
diffusée le vendredi 17 décembre c'est à
dire vendredi là à 19h en exclusivité
sur mick hannah la première saison a
cartonné la deuxième saison je vous le
dis c'est encore le niveau dessus même
au niveau de la production ou c'est un
truc de fou franchement c'est génial
bravo à vous de le coupler mercer des
travaux équipe 1 loïc tout ça tu
remarques nous acquittons carte donc à
retenir un cheat vous ferez aussi
incroyable on croit voir une trop trop
vraiment d'être repentance attendait pas
autant faire autant à la première et
carrelage et une petit truc c'est un
petit truc pour toi j'aimerais que tu
viennes un petit peu faire de du tpm
paix avec nous à la rentrée au moins une
fois par semaine je sais que dans la
voix on en avait parlé je trouve que
vraiment été génial en plus tu toujours
souriante tu aimes la vie est toi tu es
avec moi au moins et
j'ai besoin de personne avec moi dans
cette émission quelques nanas plus
jeunes voilà comment
tu peux alors j'aime pas quand tu
regardes il s'appelle quand tu dis ça
c'était un petit peu terne je sais c'est
quelqu'un voilà qui est encore là
regardez regardez regard comme elle
bouge bien encore
car est ce que ça te dirait d'être
obtenue avec nous pourquoi raconter une
fois par semaine avec un peu
et c'est vrai qu'on aura on n'a pas le
profil de carla non mais c'est vrai
voilà les photos de pernikoff qui est
pas d'accord
[Rires]
ok où il a mangé un steak frites légumes
une seule fois god l'orangeade sam et
fils aurait mangé chocolat mais aussi
qu'aucun fromage des pâtes et des pizzas
tous les trois jours c'est à dire qu'il
était en rom service sega
d'après le parisien un couple a été
particulièrement spitz année en ouvrant
ses portes et surtout sa cuisine aux
aventuriers de tf1 vous êtes dix neuf
aventuriers ici ce soir puisque il en
manque deux coumba qui est souffrante et
alix qui est obligé de respecter une
période d'isolement chez elle de retour
d'un voyage en afrique australe voilà
j'étais très sympa avec moi tueur de
lambres comme toujours
donc pourquoi denis brogniart nous dit
rien de la crise est ce qu'on peut en
faire il nous a pris pour bergman je
vais expliquer merci à lui là en
l'occurrence pour des histoires de
évident on est obligé tourné en
polynésie donc on a renforcé la sécurité
mais on est comme sur un principe de
confiance c'est à dire qu'on n'est pas
car bien de on n'est pas gardien de
prison ouais donc que l'on soit
travailler comme ça ne nous trompons pas
on est victime de ça on l'a après nous
au moment de l' annonce de thé aura donc
à trois semaines à moi on est tombé des
nues quoi donc il faut il faut des
contre une quantité sa cause la
production parce qu'il aurait dû le plus
nous surveiller vous dites quoi mais
fascinant mais c'est c'est comme si
alors vous savez on est tous des truands
donc vous le saviez qu'on était des
truands et donc vous auriez dû mettre
des gardiens plus aguerris mais on avait
des garner monfort ne les a jamais pris
pour des truands pour nous c'est des
légendes on ne veut pas donner non
d'accord c'est à dire qu'on sait moi je
voulais donner moi j'ai des trucs non
mais voilà on sait on a suffisamment de
preuves et d'épreuves réellement fondées
on a un constat une attestation
d'huissier et je voulais apporter parce
que il faut savoir que comme si la
machine
non mais c'est important c'est donc à
compter du règlement jeu ce que je sais
que vous avez règlement du jeu est
déposé ses maîtres simonin en
l'occurrence donc monsieur simona
confirmé atteste avoir reçu l'ensemble
des pièces et éléments permettant d abir
le comportement irrégulier de plusieurs
participants lors du déroulé du jeu
l'ensemble de ces pièces illustre les
manquements au code d'honneur et l
éthique général exposées dans le
règlement du jeu qui est déposé en mon
étude et justifie l'impossibilité de
déclarer un vainqueur pour cette saison
et l'idée c'est qu'on se dit voilà il ya
quand même des téléspectateurs qui
suivent assidûment ce programme mais qui
ne sont pas automatiquement au courant
de ce qui se passe parce que quand même
pas se dire ok c'est dans le parisien ok
c'est dans les réseaux sociaux mais il
ya un moment on va raconter la vraie
histoire ce qui s'est passé on va pas
nier les poteaux on va pas nier voilà
tout ça et on va surtout au site
reconnaît qu'il ya des aventuriers qui
n'ont pas triché et en l'occurrence hall
et pourquoi pas ne pas gagner tous les
aventuriers qui est pas de calais pas
triché voilà ils partent à y partager
que vous avez dit non à la friche
présence aurait pu être une option pour
ça il fallait qu'on révèle ah oui
d'accord et oui mais l'accord des
familles voulaient pas rêver les
écoliers n'ont pas révélé pourquoi parce
qu'on ne veut pas on considère qu'on est
le mois des ménages ne savait déjà mais
prend que jamais vers météorites et moi
non mais t'es où non mais on n'a pas été
bon ici
je vais finir cedeno important alors
theora déjà c'est lui qui s'est déclaré
fautif ouais c'est lui que la bravo à
lui bah ouais il prévenu se dénoncer
donc oui à ce moment là il faut se
rappeler déjà accéder pendant le
tournage il faut qu'à ce moment là bon
là je peux le bricolage rooney n'ont
rien accepté d'ailleurs sa sanction
voilà alors là je suis face à des gens
au pardon confrontés nous et je vous
dirai pas qui c'est qui nie les faits
donc il ya un moment ça s'appelle sino
de la délation mais comme vous le savez
depuis quand même long maintenant
quasiment un an et demi on saisit
régulièrement le procureur de la
république parce qu'il ya des âmes des
lynchages sur les réseaux sociaux des
appels sur
donc c'est pour ça n'étiez pas d'accord
ne veut pas de nous et qu'on en dise
alors vous l'avez peut-être vu alors la
question c'est que ce ça me sentir oui
c'est toujours moi non mais ces combats
en l'occurrence elle nous a envoyé un
certificat médical qu'est ce que je vous
dise elle l'a boycotté où elle a pas
boycotter faut lui demander à l d'accord
apparemment combat j'ai lu tu as des
infos oui n'était pas malade du tout
elle a dit très clairement qu'elle ne
voulait pas cautionner ça
et que moi je n'ai pas triché dit elle
et c'est anormal que l'on dépouille pas
donc je ne veux pas la cautionner je ne
viens pas exagérer mais pas le droit
s'est dépouillé même de toute façon j'ai
un an mais je vous dis elle vous avons
longuement d'un côté
je voulais pas venir
vous la faire jubiler on a la chance
d'avoir sébastien devaud chef de l'info
nouveau détective je suis fan du nouveau
détective recel de cadavres qu'est ce
que ça veut dire recel de cadavres le
recel de cadavre grosso modo on
soupçonne séverine donc la compagne de
cédric jubile art d'avoir caché
dissimulé ou en tout cas d'avoir aidé à
dissimuler ou cacher le bar de delphine
donc il aurait eu une complice en fait
c'est ça l'histoire exactement vous
l'avez interrogé pour votre journal là
cette femme qui est qui et la quitter la
maîtresse de
de juby de cédric jubilent à quai c'est
quoi sa personnalité c'est une femme qui
a un petit peu qui âgé de 44 ans encore
c'est une femme qui a beaucoup de
caractère tiens c'est comme maintenant
qu'ils étaient ensemble en fait
exactement quand est-ce qu'ils sont
rencontrés ils se connaissent très très
jeune enfin relativement jeunes en tout
cas on parle parfois de d'amis d'enfance
mais apparemment ça serait en avril 2021
se seraient rencontrés séverine qui
participaient à des battues à trouver un
jour un pull pensant que le pull
appartenait à delphine il a elle a
apporté à cédric qui lui a dit c'est
gentil mais c'est pas le pull de
delphine jeu c'est comme ça que leur
histoire a commencé enfin aurait
commencé parce que ya beaucoup
d'incertitudes quand même jetés alors en
fait ils ont entendu cette personne et
six autres personnes dans l'entourage de
cédric jubila ça fait presque un an
qu'elle a disparu et j'espère que les
langues vont se délier la petite soeur
de cédric joue bidart était sur écoute
téléphonique pour les besoins d'une
enquête et une conversation entre elle
et son frère a été capté par les
enquêteurs alors qualité au téléphone
avec son petit ami la jeune femme avait
oublié de raccrocher et sur ces écoutes
on entend cédric jubilaire conseiller sa
soeur sur les moyens de se défendre
lycée au détour de cette conversation il
s'est vanté d'avoir commis le crime
parfait on a un extrait regarde ce que
ginola de toi moi je suis le meurtrier
parfait pour l'instant n'oublie pas que
j'ai commis le crime parfait si tu as
besoin demande moi un mois plus tard jeu
15 juin l'adolescente est interrogé par
les gendarmes sur cette conversation ses
avocats disent mais regardez cédric et
la jeune fille de 16 ans disent que
c'est de la rigolade de la provocation
et vous pensez que s'il avait commis le
crime parfait elle se vanterait comme ça
donc ses avocats lui continue de dire
pas d'aveux pas de preuve pas de cadavre
mettez le en liberté pour moment tout
est régi ci a pas de corps ils peuvent
le maintenir en détention bien sûr mais
plus on pensait même mairie s'est brisé
bien sûr que oui bien sûr bien sûr il ya
des procès aux assises où il n'y avait
pas de corps ils ont dit avec des
éléments qui étaient tellement
importants mais que cela justifier une
mise en examen puis un procès ils ont
cherché partout du sang dans la maison
il n'y a jamais eu de ce jeu mais même
sur la couette qui est élève avec cette
chose incroyable il appelle la police à
3 heures du matin quand il dit que sa
femme est apparue la première chose
qu'il fait après appelé la police c'est
de faire tourner une machine avec les
gravats alors on est fiers at il oui
mais comme vous avez tout à fait raison
mais cette couette était vérifiée aucune
trace de sang les seules roues il entre
les deux taux à 3 heures du matin à mais
complètement c'est ça est très curieux
sa chance il n'était pas connu pour être
quelqu'un extrêmement
il ya quelque chose d'incroyable c'est
que quand tout le monde cherchait sa
femme quand tout le monde cherchait des
fines et ben lui ne cherchait pas non
mais hélas ils m'écrivent ça dans les
battues et les multiples battue comme
s'ils étaient absents ou selon les
enquêteurs comme s'il savait que ça
servait à rien de chercher donc savourer
ma maison il peut dire il peut dire oui
mais ils étaient sidérés de retourner
son attitude voilà quand même sidéré
tout le monde chez brink's le départ
d'ailleurs nié la la coupe c'est ça la
mettrais dames et brasse elle nié être
en couple avec lui rit elle elle a eu
beaucoup de versions qui ont changé dans
la presse parce qu'ils se sont connus
lors d'une battue s'est fourré et
communique par lettre puisqu'il n'a pas
le droit de recevoir des appels elle lui
écrit des lettres et gulli en prison
l'aide qui sont lus par les magistrats
avant lui arriver
[Musique]
coeur de koh lanta la légende claude
aurait dû empocher les 100 mille euros 1
bientôt c'est pour ça au final
malheureusement des soupçons de
tricherie sont venu compromettre la
finale du jeu qui n'a désigné aucun
gagnant officiel cette saison j'entends
beaucoup parler de triche mais la notion
de triche est totalement étrangère au
code du travail
dire que ce sont des salariés les
participants sont des salariés l'aspect
de production donc ils ont un certain
nombre d'obligations comme n'importe
quel salarié vis-à-vis de son employeur
mais durant son temps de travail en
dehors de son temps de travail et
retrouve toute sa liberté d'accord donc
soutenir que vous avez manqué à
certaines de vos obligations alors que
c'est en dehors de votre temps de
travail c'est totalement illégal mais
aulas quand vous avez par exemple la
production qui se défend en disant il
n'a pas respecté notre code d'honneur
mais le code d'honneur lui on peut
appeler ça une chartre un règlement
intérieur le code d'honneur et soumis au
code du travail donc il faut le
respecter bien sûr si il n'est pas
contraire au code du travail je souhaite
à claude d'intenter toutes les actions
qui lui sont ouvertes et il est certain
de les gagner et va gagner cent mille
euros il va gagner beaucoup plus ouais
et ce qui est certain c'est
énorme mais si mais si mais si ils
n'iront jamais juzan nominaux n'iront
jamais jusqu'au bout pour la simple et
bonne raison c'est que les violations et
les manquements qu'ils ont fait subir à
claude et aux autres participants ne
relève pas seulement du droit du travail
également du droit pénal et je vois mal
un dirigeant d'al paix accepté de se
défendre et d'être condamné par un
tribunal correctionnel
claude hill en guerre contre la
production oui alors c'est ce que nous
sortons demain dans public il a entamé
un bras de fer avec la prod avec donc
alp mais aussi tf1 il a contacté
plusieurs avocats dont peut-être maître
assous mais qui ne pourra pas le
confirmer
pour en fait démontré que dans un jeu
d'aventuré rechercher de la nourriture
ça fait partie des règles d'accord et
que dans le code d'honneur ce qui est ce
que ce que ce que la lp est ce que denis
brogniart a décrit comme un code
d'honneur écrit rien n'empêche les
candidats d'aller quémander de la
nourriture vous à voir que tout soit
claude
faire plier
la prod alors ça mais il faut savoir que
claude au-delà des 100 mille euros qui
lui sont passés sous le nez très
clairement mardi il ya aussi il a été
désinvité du grand concours des
animateurs par exemple il a été diffusé
sur tf1 en janvier il a prédit des
annexes et préviendra moi ça c'est pas
mal mais en revanche il devait animer un
jeu d'aventuré sur tmc cours en 2022 en
prime et là ça risque aussi de l'or de
lui et moi j'ai un concept pour claude
s'il veut il peut venir sur s'est vite
je l'accueille tout de suite claude
sachez le je veux refaire qui peut
battre et je veux faire qui peut battre
l'aude je vous le dis je le prends tout
de suite sur ces 8 dès demain voilà ce
qu'est ce qui peut récupérer les sons
binauraux qu il va récupérer beaucoup
plus mais parce que comme l'expliquait
très justement à elle voilà c'est que
non seulement il va gagner les 5000
euros parce qu'ils leur viennent et on
sait que c'est lui qui a gagné mais tout
le préjudice qu'il a subi à pour seul et
unique responsable la production et
cette espèce de mise en scène assez
grotesque de dire je ne dépouille pas
mais je vous le donne pas les noms mais
je vous fait comprendre que c'est bel et
bien lui qui aurait triché c'est encore
une fois les notions qui n'a aucune
valeur en droit du travail et ils ont
aggravé son préjudice de manière
extrêmement il sait pas là produit du
magic
vous savez que c'est la production qui
décide ce qu'on diffusait ce qu'on
diffuse pas
qu'à mis en scène cette espèce de 2,2
d'exclusion temps du jeu que social
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]